IT IS BIT.
>> Matt: THAT WAS BLOCKED OUT.
THE
HANDLING THE PUCK REALLY CLEAN.
HERE IS A CHANCE BNG IT OUT.
MARCONI WILL BRING
WAS SET UP BY
GALES.
OULD EXPECT
ARE ALL POINTING TO THE FUTURE.
>> Tyson: JOB.
NOW HE HAS WON THE NET.
>> Matt: PLAYING ACROSS, THE
SHOT IS LIKE DYSIN
MAYO AND NOW LOW.
AND THAT FELL OUT AWKWARDLY
IN THE BUSINESS.
HE CARRIED ME FOR A YEAR.
PLAY WITH GOURDE IN THE PENALTY
BACK
BOX AND A GOOD LOOK. PLAYER. TO
LAWSON CROUSE, 6'4", 250.
HE CAN
KELLER PLAYE COYOTES.
[ BUZZER ]
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF GOALS
RIGHTON'T HAVE A LOT OF THINGS
GOING ON.
COYOTES GET THE BACK-TO-BACK.
THE KRAKEN ANSWER DENIED.
SCHWARTZ AGAIN.
POPS OUT HIGH,
ALL OF A SUDDEN THIS GAME IS
WIDE POWER
PLAY.T OUT FULL GALLOP.
CUTS TO THE MIDDLE OF THE ICE.
TO GET SOMETHING GOOD, YOU HAVE
TO GIVE
PLAYOFFS.
AND YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT WILL
HAPPEN IN THE OFF ACCEPT.
>> Matt: YOU NEVER
MOVEMENT. ISSUE.
THE OTHER NIGHT IN SAN JOSE. IT
HAYTON WITH A THIS BETWEEN HIS
AND ON NET.
A
LAWSON CROUSE, AND RIGHT BACK I
KEEPING IT TO THE HIMSELF A GAM.